for this according to this
uh you are black
is that correct that is correct that is
correct
i know he's like a little jokey joke but
why job request this clip
he said oh first question i'm gonna get
him with this one you are
like huh
oh
it was just cringe it's just like like
i'm not even gonna lie i'm a
conservative but sometimes conservative
media can be so cringe
and corny i'm just like why are you
i don't i'm gonna say this pearl
your people
are interesting sometimes
i'm sorry they said
you're black
like when you when you wrote that down
sir when you that was your first thing i
want to know what your thoughts were
like ah this is this is gonna be viral
this is gonna be good
like hmm
not african-american that's not a term i
like you how come you don't like the
term ridiculous i was born and raised in
america i've never been to africa oh
that's why he did it i forgot okay okay
okay cause larry elder hates being
called african-american okay
that's why that was i'm not saying it
was a good question okay
well i'm like i think that's i was
thinking why would he do it like that i
feel like he's not that dumb yeah but i
mean you wouldn't
um
he wouldn't a half blind person could
yeah yeah but he has a whole you'll see
you'll see but
it's interesting that he says that
because i've i haven't heard
um someone else say that besides my mom
she's like she says like oh i don't like
being called african-american she said
i've never been to africa i don't i
don't know yeah like i'm not african i'm
american and i'm like it's interesting
but i'm like but you're still
black and there's still something she's
like no i'm american i'm black
but it
on the flip side for me
it's like
i understand what she's saying but it's
also frustrating because
everywhere else besides america they
for their ethnicities they say where
they're from but in america we say oh
white black brown
whatever it is it's just like well why
why are we the only place that says like
oh colors instead of like where your
bloodline is actually from
no it's interesting because we were
talking about the other day like in
europe i get asked so much more about my
heritage because guys we live in london
so they might not know
but we like even now they'll be like oh
so what are you german lithuanian yeah
irish um
way more than in america because in
america you're just white yeah
and it
it's frustrating and i've had someone
ask me like well how does it feel like
when people ask you that question it it
sucks in a sense i'm like i want to be
able to say like oh i'm i'm from here
i'm from there because it's so cool to
be able to like know where your family's
from but when people ask me i just go
i'm just i'm just black not just black
but it's like
i'm i'm black i don't know where my
bloodline is and i can't specifically
say
oh
africa because i i don't know yes i'm
black i don't know have you ever looked
at doing the dna test i have but i'm
like trying to decide on which one if
y'all if y'all know
which one to do because i've heard some
of them like use your information for
other stuff i'm like don't be spreading
my dna everywhere thank you but if you
if you know a good one let us know in
the comments down below please
because i want to know
correct that is correct that is correct
not african-american that's not a term i
like you how come you don't like the
term ridiculous i was born and raised in
america i've never been to africa uh
how why am i an african-american most of
my people have been here longer than
most of other the other people in this
room uh yet most people don't have a
hyphen uh you know i'm an italian
american greek american roommate oh my
god that's so interesting
i don't even think about it like that
because
like i have a grandparent from lithuania
or great grandparent from lithuania and
another one from germany
huh
yeah so like if
if
i have a friend who born and raised in
africa and they move to the states
i i don't know if they're i don't think
they're a citizen right now but if they
were to become a citizen they would
technically be
african-american because they are they
were from straight from africa and that
is their main residence and then they
have another dual citizenship in america
which is african-american if we're going
like based off like the actual
like the term the term of it
romanian-american it's an absurd term
it's a term that jesse jackson is almost
single-handedly crammed down the throats
of our media and after jackson began to
talk about why blacks should uh have
some connection to africa all of a
sudden new york times l.a times all of
the media began using that expression
it's ridiculous yeah i mean i personally
don't use the term african-american that
much because one time i had a guest on
the show and i referred to her as
african-american and she said well i'm
actually jamaican
so you know what i mean so i guess that
that goes
and i remember reading one time dave
somebody uh was given a description of
some suspect who had done some crime was
running away uh and uh he was described
as an african-american how do you know
where he was from it could have been
from africa it could be from jamaica
could be from canada so what do you mean
what do you make of that when someone
like because i know you really rail
against jesse jackson and these guys on
the left that use and i want to talk a
lot about identity politics okay so the
guys that use these phrases what what
are they going for there
well they're what is their goal the goal
is to
tell black people that we're victims
that discrimination and racism remain
major problems in america when in fact
they don't uh and uh
oh
pearl
this video
i'm not saying anything i'm not saying
anything
i'm i'm like interested to see like what
he says and like how he says it
because
in
in the black community if you
if you don't agree with the majority
they
they call you all kinds of things that i
cannot say on camera um
but
they
they like dismiss you in a sense
and
particularly i don't like it it's like
if if another black person has a
different view what's the what's the
difference between us having a different
view and someone that looks like me
having a different view like we're not
all the same we don't all think the same
but it's like we all have to and that's
like the the feeling that the black
community not everybody but majority and
it sucks like why can't we think
differently he's been he's was born
raised in l.a went to the east coast for
school and the midwest so he's touched
almost every sector of the states like
the big sectors of the state to be able
to see different things and experience
different things and experience
racism or not racism in his lifetime and
so why can't he talk about things that
he sees a different way and he's
been in law know the law and it's like
it sucks that
when people talk like this it's just
missed right away and like not enough
people actually sit down and like listen
be like okay never saw from that point i
still don't agree with it maybe but i
understand where you're coming from well
it's interesting you say that because he
says that all the time on his platform
that like like he that they call him
like a
i'm not gonna say
you're the animal
not
uncle oh uncle tom no but there's some
other ones yeah i'm not gonna yeah i'm
not gonna
the worst comments he gets are from his
own community yeah and it it sucks
because i'm like
how
how are we going to tell other people
to support
our own community
when even inside our own community we
can't even fully support each other when
we agree or disagree it's like
you don't think the same way as me and
you black okay
bye i don't want to listen to you but we
want other people to listen to us other
people to understand us and the things
we go through and whatever it is but we
can't even first do that in our own home
how how do you expect other people to do
that
if we're not doing it like we have to
set an example at first and i don't
think people really think of it like
that it's like no we this has been done
to us we all have to think the same we
all have to be the same and it may not
be that for everybody but from my
experience of what i've seen and what
i've just witnessed just in my life
that's that's my experience that's what
i've seen you know what's interesting i
think there's a lot more black
conservatives than people really know
and i know this just from like doing my
platform
i've had so many people like that that
are like acquaintances be like liking my
stuff and like commenting you know what
i mean like my conservative stuff like
um
it's interesting because i think it's
i think there's more like
like conservative about like black
people with conservative values than you
would think you know what i mean
i would agree with that
but because
of the way
the community is set up they may not
come out and speak about it as much
because of the backlash they would get
from it so no i've had people send me
dms where they're like i could never say
this in public but like i love what
you're doing
yeah and it's just like
it sucks because it's like
we
we want to
be able to be our 100
authentic self to everybody else in the
world but we get backlash from it but we
also get backlash from our own community
and it's like
why
why is that and i could never for the
life of me understand why
they want black people to vote for the
democratic party the democratic party
gets 95 of the black vote uh and the
reason they get it is because blacks are
convinced that the number one issue
facing the country right now is social
justice racist white cops uh
discrimination systemic racism
microaggression whatever new word they
come up with and it's a bunch of
nonsense the number one problem
domestically facing this country is a
breakdown of the family and president
obama said it i didn't a a a black kid
or a kid not just a black kid a kid
raised without a dad is five times more
likely to be poor and commit crimes nine
times more likely to drop out of school
and 20 times more likely to end up in
jail so you're far more likely to end up
in jail without having a dad than you
are because of a white racist cop right
i wonder what the
statistics are for people who
may have had
a dad but wasn't like
present he was just there just like
provided went to work came home and
didn't like interact with them or like
try to build a relationship with them i
wonder what the stats are that if
they're like similar or
it really doesn't matter
i have no idea might have worked a lot
yeah that turned out okay
i'd be chilling
[Laughter]
so but you wouldn't not acknowledge that
there are some systemic issues give me
an example tell me what you think the
most systemic racist issue is what is it
well i would say that because black
people in most cases in many cases were
descendants of slaves that racism as a
as an institution that it's just 2000 a
certain amount of it just exists 2015.
give me the most blatant racist example
you can come up with right now um
i think you could probably find evidence
that
in general cops are that cops are more
willing
to
shoot if the uh perpetrator is black
what's your data then white what's your
basis for saying that last year well
look i know a lot of people would say
look what's going on in china i know
what they would say i'm talking about
what the facts are 965 people were shot
by cops last last year and killed four
percent of them were white cops shooting
unarmed blacks in in chicago in 2011 21
people were shot and killed by cops uh
in 2015 there were seven
in chicago which is a third black a
third white and third hispanic 70 of the
homicides are black on black about 40
per month almost 500 in the
per year last year in chicago and 75 of
them are unsolved where is the black
lives matter on that the idea that a
racist white cop uh and shooting unarmed
black people is apparel to black people
is bs
bro you're set me up
i'm sorry oh this is the setup now i'm
feeling um
again my mom has had this conversation
with me and i'm like
that's not what we're talking about
right now we need to defend that
and
it's it's hard
because
it's like i want to
it's like all right
we see it
we see it a lot
but also
we see
what social media like pushes and
everything and they don't
they really don't push
any other incidents when it comes to
cop related stuff the
from what i've seen on social media they
push a lot of
um
cops doing things to blast suspects
whatever it is and i'm not saying that
it doesn't happen
it's just
i wonder if
all of
the
the information is being
um
is being like put in the system
and if like those stats are 100 i'm not
saying that they're incorrect i'm just
like i wonder i wonder if they're all
being put in there
and
it's ah you okay you're gonna i'm gonna
tell you something and once you see this
you can't unsee it no there's been so
many things pearl that you that i've
seen that i know
remember the media is gonna push things
to control people okay because a lot of
people that are like running and stuff
are like behind some of the big media
companies like they have money invested
or whatever
watch whenever black lives matter is the
loudest
who think who's getting elected
when did
black lives matter like in now right
have you heard anything the last couple
months
i've heard that homegirl bought a
million dollar house who the the creator
of black lives matter okay okay but i
mean like anything in the anything in
the media that happened with cops now
when's the what's the last one you
remember oh my
pearl
no what's the last one you remember
what is the last one i remember
when there's protests
i think george floyd was the last one
when was it
what was that what it was yeah
what was happening the election
pearl now what was the other really big
one
was it the one in the wendy's parking
lot
um i was thinking of
tiana first i was thinking of ferguson
okay
that was like the other huge one where
it was like and what was going on an
election
and so it's like
put and i'm not
i don't think i know enough to like say
like oh there's no race like i would
never say that right
but i just think it's weird how this
stuff is always quiet after the election
yeah very loud right before i've i've
noticed that i've noticed that around
election times i'm like there's
always there's always something that
happens around election time you can
never like
not there's never something not
happening around election time
and you know what else is weird where
they raised so much money
where did it go
oh it was to her house yeah what has
black lives matter done
she bought her a
million dollar house and that's
something i saw on the internet so i'm
not just saying it like like imagine how
much money they rate like like um george
floyd was huge that was national
headlines
they they have i don't know how much
money they raised but it had to be
ridiculous amounts that could find
schools that could fund a lot of things
that could really
they had people some heavy hitters
behind them
and what and what laws did they did they
passed you know what's crazy do you know
who actually did pass the law
to get rid of like the chokeholds
trump
he i don't remember exactly what the law
was
but he's he's
like i don't even know what like what
exactly like what's on their agenda like
what are they like what tangible results
do they want yeah
i have a friend um
that
didn't support black lives matter in the
back of my head i'm like well why not
and i have it's
my friend's back at home i have
a friend group that um
that typically like kind of thinks the
same but we have like deep conversations
but i have a friend that me and her we
go back and forth and we talk about
stuff like this because
she
she thinks more like you she um she
voted for trump and everything and i'm
like wow like why but we were able to
sit down and talk about it and
she talked about how she didn't support
black lives matters because she looked
into it and like what they actually
supported and the things behind them she
was like yeah no i don't support them
like
i don't care if it says black lives
matter like yes it does
black lives do matters but not the
things you support within that
interest i just i don't see them as an
effective
organization like i don't know what
they're like i i understand like the
sentiment right and i'm with them with
that
but like
what what policies are you trying to
change yeah because from what you did
what impact what changed from
this like were people just acknowledged
that black lives matter or people or
were like black lives changed from it
because the other thing is like there's
always going to be racist people like
there's oh like you can't you can't get
rid of so saying to racist people stop
being racist isn't gonna do anything
like that if it was that easy then there
wouldn't be no racism right
and so it's like what you can't really
do anything with that but like what what
laws can we put in place to help the
situation yeah and i don't like i i
don't i couldn't even tell you and i
should be able to if it's national
headlines yeah
wow
oh goodness we're only we're not even 10
minutes into this video
just let's just play the video here we
go it's complete and total bs and and
the reason for
these so-called activists saying this is
the assumption that racism remains a
major problem in america the media cnn
especially msnbc runs down whenever a
black cop shoots somebody uh and it and
it's some some march on washington it's
ridiculous uh black people half the
homicides in this country are committed
by and against black people last year
there were 14 000 homicides not talking
about suicide talking about homicides
half of them were black 96 percent of
them black on black of that 7 000.
where's the black black lives matter
people on that so that there's where you
would say that this is purely because of
social justice purely because they want
ultimately for people to be angry enough
to just keep voting democrats that's
right and where's the evidence of a lack
of social justice when a black
suspect is killed by by a cop
believe me the media is on it people are
watching it
and
and justice will will
for the most part occur in baltimore
where freddie gray was killed
i
i
hate that the statistic
is so high for
like crime within the black community
it's
it's frustrating and i wish it wasn't
that way
at all because i'm like why
excuse me like i said earlier why are we
from the inside
going after each other like
bump whoever
whoever this person is or that person is
whatever gang they grew up and i
i despise
i i just don't like i like what they
were initially supposed to do
the gangs and how they're supposed to
help the community now it's just games
are supposed to help the i don't know
anything about so um it was a
documentary i
watched and
when they set up from what i remember
has been a minute when they set up the
games it was initially supposed to help
the community and it teach certain
things to whoever decided to come into
the gang it wasn't supposed to be
a battlefield and wherever you
walk on the street you got to make sure
you're not looking this way or doing
that the second third now a days i
people may come for me and be like well
you don't know nothing about it i don't
know anything about it i just see the
product of it and i don't like it
um and so
i'm not saying that's the only reason
why the statistic is high but i just
don't i don't like that that is a
statistic because there's
if you if we could eliminate everything
that's all the junk that is happening
within
like the black community to where that
statistic is so high
i feel like a lot of things would change
but it's like we have to look inward
first
and
what he was talking about with the um
the cops and the um
the cops killing the uh black people
i think the argument comes
when
they're
when the situation is what it is and
they're unarmed for me whenever i hear
that or hear any situation i'm like why
why isn't there more
training for cops so i know there's not
a lot of training for cops i'm not
saying they're like incompetent but why
isn't there
more training to where if
you're in
if you feel like you're in danger shoot
somebody to injure them instead of
shooting somebody to
kill them innocence i know that when
you're in a situation you may not be
thinking about that but that is your
job to do that
and so
when i hear people say
there's a
is different oh that's that's what i
think about like
well if they're unarmed why
why is a gun in the situation
like why is that why isn't a taser
something that you pull out first
so um i'm going to give you a little bit
something that changed my perspective a
little bit on that so i used to sell
copiers okay and i sold copiers to this
company that trained police officers and
that was like they had like a virtual
reality where you had to pick whether
you're gonna like shoot someone
and like they let me do it right it's so
hard because you don't know if they're
reaching for a gun
because it happens so quick like you
don't know if they're reaching for a gun
or if they're reaching for uh um
like it could it could just be a cell
phone
and so but if they can't see your hand
they don't know yeah
and that's that's like why a lot of
times they'll be like hands up hands up
and if people don't listen like it puts
it puts themselves in danger
both of them yeah and
it's i'm just telling you it's harder
than you think oh i i believe in that
situation
i probably wouldn't be able to say what
i'm saying right now i'd be like
i'm nervous and what about okay the i
can't remember the exact case but the
one that was like when we were we would
have been in high school or maybe like
early high school
um where that guy was like punching the
police officer
you think in that case he should have
been shot
because dude was like because he was
trying to grab the officer's gun
i don't remember that case but i think
it was ferguson i'm pretty sure
and that's how the media painted it that
it was like this unarmed guy
but really man was trying to take his
gun
[Music]
and i mean and it was like this really
big dude with this small police officer
he was trying to take it and then he got
shot like
a million times yeah but
like
see it's
like
because that happens like you can get
shot with your own gun oh yeah for sure
and i understand that it's just
there's just certain situations just
like oh was like it's hard because it
you would think
one shot would be able to like stun
somebody but you have some people out
here that are
that
one shot and they're like they eat it
they eat it for breakfast and then
they're like one shot ain't gonna do
nothing to me and
and then you have to like send off
different rounds and i'm not justifying
it but it's just it's difficult because
as a police officer you're concerned
about your own safety and i don't know
if there should be
more things implemented in the beginning
to put them in those like
difficult situations and to
make see how they react when
they're put in
a situation where they may not
particularly like somebody or they have
some unbiased opinion or unbiased
something about
a suspect and put those put them in the
situation to see how how would they
react and ask them like well why did you
react like that and if it's
not to
protect themselves or if it's just off
of an unbiased opinion then it's like
okay how can we get it to where we are
conducting conducting things correctly
as a police officer and
um
and in a way that protects us but also
protects
whoever it is in this situation i i also
think body cam footage is a good thing
i think it protects both parties oh yes
for sure i think like i don't have a
problem with body cam yeah
nah i think that's a i think that's a
good thing
freddie ray died in a van i shouldn't
say was killed died in a van you have a
city that's uh 45
black
city council is 100 democrat the
majority of city council is black the
top cop at the time was was black the
number two cop was black the majority of
the command staff is black the the mayor
is black uh the ag is black uh and yet
here we are talking about racism i mean
it's it's absurd yeah absurd so it's
funny i find myself caught in between
this a little bit as a liberal where i
want to always try to defend the other
so in this case the other being black
people i'm always sympathetic to that
and that yeah yeah at the same time i
hear you laying out a pretty solid well
just the fact i'll tell you something
else too there was just a study uh
university of washington
uh and it turns out cops were more
reluctant more hesitant to pull the
trigger against a black black suspect
than a white suspect uh probably because
of the fear of being accused of racially
profiling and the fear that the civil
rights establishment was going to come
down on him so if anything uh whites are
more likely to be shot by a cop under
under certain circumstances than a than
a black person and in last 30 or 40
years the number of percentage of
suspects killed by cops who are black
has declined 75
however the percentage of whites killed
by cops has flatlined yeah and so if
anything people are more concerned about
shooting black people for fear that
they're going to be called racist and
almost all every one of these incidents
whether it's eric gardner in in new york
who died because he was selling lucy's
and resisted arrest whether it's tamir
rice in cleveland who was twirling
around the gun whether it's michael
brown and ferguson
who had just uh committed an ar strong
armed robbery almost every one of these
incidents involved somebody resisting
arrest why don't you just do what the
police tell you my dad said when i get
pulled over have my hand at 10 o'clock
have my hand at two o'clock say yes sir
say no sir make sure my paperwork is in
order and if i feel the cop is
mistreating me get a badge number and
deal with it later on if jeff
it's oh
i i understand and hear what he's saying
it's just hard for when though there's
those situations where
people did like
not resist and they did everything and
it still resulted in yeah
the terrible ending it's like well
what do you what do you do about that
like how how can you justify that do you
think that's the norm
i'm just from your experience like with
you with police and like with your
friends with police do you do you find
that to be the exception or the rule
um
and i'm not swaying either way like it's
whatever i
i don't know because i've heard about
um incidents like that and i've had
friends who had family members that were
in positions like that and it resulted
badly and i
i don't know if that's the norm it's
like there's a
i've heard in california it's actually
worse
would you agree i've heard in california
it's actually bad
yeah and so that's why i'm
surprised not surprised but
interested that he has the view that he
has because of
where he's from and how california is
especially la county it's
l.a county is a state in itself it has
so many people that live there and
there's just been
it's a lot in la and i can't speak on it
speak on it because i haven't lived
there for
a long amount of time to be able to
speak on it but
it's hard when
he says this and
said oh all you have to do is this isn't
this
but then like
we
we do it but something still ha that
happens and then you have people like i
shouldn't have to do all that but it's
like you
if this is what you need to do to
essentially
put yourself in a better situation and
not
make make anything make the cop feel
uncomfortable then comply
but it's like
it's
because i think the other problem is
there's power hungry people yes like if
anything if anything like
i think the biggest problem with police
if you is you get those guys that are
just so excited to have any ounce of
like authorities
and they just want to like tell you what
to do yes and they just want to be a
dick and an [ __ ] for no reason like i
really
honestly um
i didn't like i've always had
interactions with the cops that were
fine but i had a cousin
that
was addicted to drugs so he was he was
very much involved with police but like
he had a lot of really bad you know
experiences but at the same time he was
also a crackhead
so i'm like
you might have done something yeah it
might have been your own fault
but so but i don't so for me i haven't
really had issues but i've seen
like mostly at parties in college where
the police are just like
they're just dying yeah to have
something to do
and be a dick for no reason and i feel
like
there's more
there's more cops like that that are
giving just
police officers a bad rep it's just the
ones that
are
money hungry that have that want to be
in that sense of power and don't know
how to properly use it and that's
something that i've thought about and i
think i forgot who i was having this
conversation with
about that and it's like
if you
our police officer
you should put away whatever bias
whatever you feel about any type of
person because now your job is to
protect
said person that you do not like and if
you are in a situation to where you
put your bias in front of what you're
supposed to do you don't need to you
need to take off that badge and step
away from it because
what about if a doctor
is supposed to be able to help
anybody and everybody in whatever they
study and you come in and they look at
you like i don't like gingers so i can't
help you and you're like about to die
it's like no you
you cannot
do that because
as a
as that job you're you're for all people
no matter what you do when you go home
matter what you think when you go home
when you step inside that job that is
your job to do that and i feel like
there's just
there's cops that forget that and they
have their bias and their
their proudness that they want to insert
in every situation and
it gives the ones that are actually
trying to make a change a bad name and
so they just group them all together and
they say all cops are bad when i know
that there's some good cops out there
that want to make a change and want to
make a difference you know what's
interesting
so i had a guy at my school that was
like arrested by police okay
and
he
um i think he was arrested illegally or
some i don't know exactly what happened
but he was like crying about how the
police were so mean to him whatever but
i was at that party
so you're being an [ __ ] to them like
he was like super drunk he was like
all
like like dude i mean so then they
turned on the camera for the five
minutes the police were like kind of
rude back but i'm like you didn't get in
the part where he was like you have like
20 18 year olds here that are smoking
doing like it's illegal you can't
so i don't know it's like i see both
sides because on one hand i see these
power hungry cops that just wanna are
like they're just so excited to have
power but then i see these teenagers
that are being a dick to police for no
reason
yeah and so it's like i kind of i see
both you know yeah